[Musik]
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen hier mittlerweile schon zu
dritten folge von in der letzten folge
episoden mit luca sind wir dort stehen
geblieben wo blair mit lola nun
nachsitzen musste weil reilly sie beim
lehrer verletzt hat und da machen wir
zweiter
ich glaube lola hass und steven trend is
your friend
dann bin ich schuld ein lob sagt mister
grunebaum hier beim nachsitzen
in silence biologie zeilen lola have to
fix ist ja wir müssen ja immer noch lola
rumkriegen weil wir sind ja lesbisch ein
niedriger das auto auf die menschen also
wir müssen raus außen nachwuchs raum
impress mister gummibaum breitwieser
grünbaum oder blackmail ist angesagt wie
im pressen den also versuchen den lehrer
zu beeindrucken reading about picasso
everything about what we are family lift
in paris alles klar blanc in china
sondern paris gelebt momente player bei
deinem nothing you are a lot of
attention
no matter how much is true power cool
das ist glaube ich nicht das schlimmste
was man einem lehrer sollte blood award
romaco dir picasso had one world in his
way you can tell me all of them are
roulette und lola auf detention okay
also müssen alle
neu
er möchte von allen guten geistern auf
jeden fall sehr beeindruckt und mister
umbau des jugend able to dat wie vor
congratulations steht hier also wahnsinn
johann die nachrichtenagentur pa
ich weiß noch nicht was vor stück das
bedeutet wir sind einfach jetzt beste
homies change my mind okay also wir
können jetzt tatsächlich das nachsitzen
verlassen zusammen mit lola und sie
freut sich mal schauen wie es weitergeht
wir sind vor der kenwood academy of
recording us autors james
dankl oder und was wollen wir auch noch
gut sind
im küssen wir waren diese ganze kunst
kkr halt gerade wirklich nur weil wir
uns lola klar machen müssen bei wir
diese kissel ist challenge haben gegen
reilly gegen unseren er aber gut wir
schauen mal wie es weitergeht jetzt ein
für die götter des ostrings sagt blair
healey beide lachen ok reilly steht
daneben und denkt sich auf gott online
okay sie kommen schon böse an
have you only with you had sagt blair
die fahrt ist ein city of london einem
gerade gerne hier ok logistik rinteln 1
pm
wir haben nämlich immer noch ein date
heute abend zu kunst ist es die
beginning sagt reilly gibt my business
to make sure you fährt er wieder und
bringen sagt leo caic daneben move along
reilly ok credit suisse ag
er hat ja auch unser wahrzeichen auf dem
schädel ist ist ja mein mann ist wie man
wie mein bruder hat die tante des kurses
mit your shoes der kennwort erkennen wir
dürfen nicht auf den rasen mit schuhen
darf ich auf jeden fall hin auch auf die
schule bei reilly sagte player tanks mit
der grüne baum anything for you ist ja
unser hobby hier mit auf jeden fall
wieder ein schwarzer immer schauen wir
sind zu hause in unserem kleiderschrank
und keine ahnung der geist steht von
meinem kleiderschrank also
wahrscheinlich würde ich gerade
experiment machen schweigend für die
zeit what you were mensch das hätte ich
ja jetzt gar nicht vermuten können lauda
special dress to inspire hockey wolle
package ist reif sagt jenner also ein
paket von lola als angekommen im
playback street art whitmore gott diese
lola ist echt so ein richtiger kunst
fanatiker
ich sehe immer aus wie kunst oder guckt
die diese visage an inspire me by
wearing the south african painting
masterpiece mein gott
ok darf ich raten an ich muss das
wahrscheinlich kaufen gebe ich 20
jemanden aus alles für die lola alter
der munich an belege blieb allerdings
offen
wir können ja
jetzt sehen wir allerdings wieder reilly
hier muss so hat blair der letzten nacht
sagt sie sie ruft gegen den an halloween
thing to report diebe an einen gott
die
nein die mal doch
das ist nicht wahr
die kommen sie nein jetzt kommt die cops
alter
ok also sie macht weiter und ich muss
jetzt die polizisten aufhalten but how
also wie sollen wir das ganze anstellen
oh mein gott das ist alles nicht dazu
die besten möglichkeiten ich würde
allerdings sagen mit zündenden mülltonne
an weil das würde ich gern mal sehen wer
läuft auf jeden fall lang hat natürlich
ein feuerzeug dabei und direkt brennt
auch die mülltonne sie lacht sich da auf
jeden fall schrott und die kopf sagen
radio one ein
okay die beiden polizisten gehen in die
karibik fahren natürlich zu mit zwei
karten auf einen zu einer brennenden
mülltonne alles klar okay ja sie sollen
hierfür abgelenkt und allein gott ist
und fertig oder kannst mich jetzt bitte
dann küssen its masterpiece lola clever
ironie profi und als trainer steht we
dare to you sagt ihk beide lachen und
die polizei kommt trotzdem die cops are
coming back office rent die beiden
rennen weg neben eine gasse der rock n
roll up in der der banden warehouse oh
mein gott okay sie verstecken sich jetzt
in einem verlassenen warenhaus
ok wenn da jetzt nix geht alter dann
weiß ich nicht hier stehen auf jeden
fall jetzt auf dem dach und sehen wie
die polizisten an uns vorbeifahren
deshalb minute rooney inspiring neidet
can still get better beiden kommen sich
näher
[Musik]
menschen ziemlich abstoßende klux klan
social probably had homo wie can stop
des monats wie may comeback beim
workshop mit ok lola ganz kurze passt
nur teil einer wette und deswegen habe
ich dich geküsst hilft ihr könnt ihn the
date with no loss of york war dein herr
blue ergänzt reilly wahnsinn
also ist unser lehrer jetzt auch teil
des codes von blair und mir da was ja
einige nur auf meine inspiring news sagt
die lola in the wanted something you
lola wie bereits gesagt was teil einer
wette und ich muss jetzt weitermachen
mit der kissel ist also nimmst die pc
nicht persönlich aber du warst nur ein
kleiner stein in meinem garten
trotzdem natürlich kennen gelernt zu
haben
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen des
buddha oder has been pretty fan denkt
sich die blende und workshops ich sage
aber endlich hier weil ich hab wirklich
keinen bock darauf mit diesen workshop
anzuschauen einem audio im ok lola
bringt uns noch nach hause und die kiste
ist ist abgehakt
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir direkt
schaffen uns lohnt zu klären aber ich
habe natürlich auch wieder fünf euro
bezahlt
lola haben wir auf jeden fall
abgearbeitet von der kissel ist also
zurück in der kennt wurde demi und im
schulsaal beziehungsweise im schulflur
everyone stars am ural great basin
bestwert ja das war aber nur weil ich
die mülltonne angezündet habe und die
polizei abgelenkt habe generali
inspiring konzerttermin houston street
artisten okay also wir kriegen auf jeden
fall den respekt so you got your first
class denn ich bin sexy im gegensatz zu
dir ich antworte einfach mal die first
of many und sie antwortet big deal juni
das braucht noch mehr
aber gut
also in der heutigen folge haben wir
personen 1 abgearbeitet auf der kissel
ist oder in der nächsten folge kommen
dann zu zweit in person von daher will
ich das heutige video der ist jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
diese dritte episode episode mit mit
luca gefallen hat dass die daumen hoch
und dem video da ist schreib mir mal und
in die kommentare
ob das projekt weitergehen soll und ob
ich mir als nächstes gleichen jungen
klären soll oder wieder ein mädchen ihr
dürft entscheiden schreibt sie gern und
in die kommentare abonniert zudem gern
meinen kanal falls sie noch kein teil
der luxus sei das ist kostenlos und dem
verpasst keine videos mehr und ich sehen
wir das wollten dass ich meine videos
anschauen gar keine potenziell zumas zum
warum niemand
[Musik]